we're now going to move directly into
our third session we move to the topic
of Lincoln and the Constitution the
Constitution and the Civil War and to
introduce our speaker today I'm going to
call upon Hillsdale College Jr Gabriel
skiver Gabriel is interning as part of
the whip program he's in the office of
Congressman Steve King from Iowa Gabriel
thank you dr. Bob Palmer Ito is the
William and Bernice group chair and
constitutional history dean of faculty
and associate professor of history at
Hillsdale College he earned his ba magna
[ __ ] Laden his MA at the State University
of New York and Albany and his ph in
history from the University of Maryland
at College Park dr. Marino is the author
of black Americans and organized labor a
new history and from direct action to
affirmative action Fair Employment Law
and Policy in America he is published
widely in journals such as law and
history review the Journal of southern
history and the Journal of policy
history please join me in welcoming dr.
Marino as he speaks on his topic the
Constitution and the savour thank you
and like to say I'm very grateful to the
kirby center for the invitation to speak
at this event and to be part of this
effort to revive the Constitution I'd
also just like to recommend a couple of
things to read on this topic of Lincoln
the civil war in the Constitution one is
a collection of essays by Herman belt
was my graduate director and the
pre-eminent historian of civil war-era
constitutionalism Abraham Lincoln
constitutionalism and equal rights in
the Civil War era published by fordham
university press and of course the best
place to look to for Lincoln's political
thinking is in the works of Lincoln
himself the dazzler edition of Lincoln's
edited version of Lincoln's collected
works is also very very useful this
morning I'm going to attempt to give an
account of
Lincoln statesmanship and constitutional
efforts to preserve the Union as a
historian not a political theorist I'm
going to focus on what Lincoln did to
save the Union nevertheless much of what
I'm going to cite as historical evidence
consists of Lincoln's words Lincoln was
a statesman not a philosopher but he
certainly understood and expressed the
fundamental concepts of American
political philosophy a large part of
what Lincoln did to save the Union and
to make it forever worthy of the saving
involved words the most important thing
the Lincoln did was to define the Union
and by definition I mean to give greater
clarity to focus or to bring out detail
to something that's already visible it
is not to add or detract from or to
transform or transcend or alter the
thing it is like the restorative work of
clearing off the effects of age or
corrosion on a work of art or it is like
an HDTV giving us a better image of a
football game in Lincoln's speech at
Peoria in 1854 he said let us read opt
the Declaration of Independence and with
it the practices and policy which
harmonize with it let North and South
let all Americans let all lovers of
Liberty everywhere join in the great and
good work if we do this we shall not
only have saved the Union but we shall
have so saved it as to make and keep it
forever worthy of the saving we shall
have so saved it that succeeding
millions of free happy people the world
over shall rise up and call us blessed
to the last generations now what did
Lincoln mean by making the Union forever
worthy of the saving first of all what
did Lincoln mean by the Union the union
was not the Constitution exactly Lincoln
argued that the union is much older than
the Constitution he said it was formed
in fact by the articles of association
in 1774 it was matured and continued by
the declaration of independence in 1776
it was further matured and the faith of
the other than thirteen states expressly
plighted and engaged that it should be
perpetual
the Articles of Confederation in 1778
and finally in 1787 one of the declared
objects for ordaining and establishing
the Constitution was to form a more
perfect union the constitution of 1789
was us an instrument for the perfection
of the Union and the Constitution had
other ends to serve to establish justice
insure domestic tranquility provide for
the common defense promote the general
welfare and secure the blessings of
liberty to ourselves and our posterity
the union is at the head of this list in
the preamble of the Constitution but the
union is instrumental to the rest of the
list justice peace security welfare and
liberty and the last of the list Liberty
is really primary I believe it was so
for Lincoln that for Lincoln the Union
and the Constitution or we might say
constitutional union was for the sake of
Liberty and it was more precisely for
the sake of liberty of a particular kind
a Liberty based upon human equality in
1864 Lincoln said the world has never
had a good definition of the word
Liberty and the American people just now
are much in want of one we all declare
for liberty button using the same word
we do not all mean the same thing with
some the word Liberty may mean for each
man to do as he pleases with himself and
the product of his labor well with
others the same word may mean for some
men to do as they please with other men
and the product of other men's labor
here are to not only different but
incompatible things called by the same
name Liberty and it follows that each of
the things is by the respective parties
called by two different and incompatible
names liberty and tyranny the Shepherd
drives the wolf from the sheep's throat
for which the Sheep thanks the Shepherd
as a liberator while the wolf denounces
him for the same act as a destroyer of
Liberty especially as the sheep was a
black one plainly the sheep and the wolf
are not agreed upon a definition of the
word Liberty and precisely the same
difference prevails today among us human
creatures even in the north and all
professing to love liberty hence we
behold the processes by which thousands
our daily passing from under the yoke of
bondage hailed by some as the advance of
liberty and bewail by others as a
destruction of all liberty it was the
work of Lincoln's life to ensure that
the union was saved on this
understanding of liberty of Liberty
grounded in natural equality as
president-elect Lincoln put it in a
speech at Independence Hall in
Philadelphia all the political
sentiments I entertain have been drawn
as far as I've been able to draw them
from the sentiments which originated and
were given to the world from this hall
in which we stand I have never had a
feeling politically that did not spring
from the sentiments embodied in the
Declaration of Independence I have often
pondered over the dangers which were
incurred by the men who assembled here
and adopted that declaration of
independence I have pondered over the
toils that were endured by the officers
and soldiers of the army who achieved
that independence I have often inquired
of myself what great principle or idea
it was that kept this Confederacy so
long together it was not the mere matter
of separation of the colonies from the
motherland but something in that
declaration giving Liberty not alone to
the people of this country but hope to
the world for all future time it was
that which gave promise that in due time
the weights should be lifted from the
shoulders of all men and that all should
have an equal chance this is the
sentiment embodied in the Declaration of
Independence human equality was the
central principle of the Declaration and
thus of the Union and the Constitution
and a great part of Lincoln's legacy was
his further definition of equality he
did not alter or add to the founders
definition of equality but clarified
expounded or construed it in his debates
with Stephen Douglas who like Chief
Justice Roger tawny in the Dred Scott
case denied that the principles of
equality applied to blacks if indeed it
applied to individuals at all Lincoln
said that Lincoln said this is the
founders I think that the authors of
that notable instrument intended to
include all men but they did not mean to
declare all men equal in all respects
they did not mean to say that all men
were equal in color size intellect moral
development or social capacity they
defined with tolerable distinctness in
what they did consider all men created
equal equal in certain inalienable
rights among which are life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness this they said
and this they meant they did not mean to
declare the they did not mean to assert
the obvious untruth that all were then
actually enjoying that equality nor yet
that they were about to confer it
immediately upon them in fact they had
no power to confer such a boon they
meant simply to declare that the right
so that the enforcement of it might
follow as fast as circumstances should
permit they meant to set up a standard
Maxim for free society which should be
familiar to all constantly looked to
constantly labored for and even though
never perfectly attained constantly
approximated and thereby constantly
spreading and deepening its influence
and augmenting the happiness and value
of life to all people of all colors
everywhere Lincoln maintain that the
Equality of men was the central idea of
our political and constitutional system
while there was always inequality as a
matter of actual necessity it's constant
working has been a steady progress
toward the practical equality of all men
the American people formed the union in
the Constitution to preserve Liberty
based upon equality as Lincoln expressed
it our national prosperity depended on
the Constitution and the union and there
was a philosophical cause behind these
the principle of Liberty to all in the
Declaration of Independence Lincoln said
the assertion of that principle at that
time was the word fitly spoken which has
proved an apple of gold to us referring
to the 25th proverb a word fitly spoken
is like apples of gold and pictures of
silver in Lincoln's analogy the Union
and the Constitution are the picture of
silver subsequently framed around it the
picture was made not to conceal or to
destroy the Apple but to adorn it and
preserve it Lincoln's work in defining
the Constitution was too
make the picture of silver better adorn
the apple of gold to make the fit the
frame fit more perfectly the subject at
the OREA where he called us to readapt
the Declaration of Independence Lincoln
said our Republican robe is soiled and
trailed in the dust let us reap yura Phi
it let us turn and wash it white in the
spirit if not the blood of the
revolution again the work of definition
was to cleanse and restore the founding
documents one of the most important
rhetorical tools that Lincoln used to
shape our understanding of the
Constitution and the union was history
in large part the entire debate between
Lincoln and Douglas was a historical
argument constantly returning to the
question of how the American founders
understood the phrase all men are
created equal the greater part of the
Peoria speech was a historical narrative
the veracity of which Lincoln showed do
concern for this is the repeal of the
Missouri Compromise Lincoln said of
Douglass's kansas-nebraska act the
foregoing history may not be precisely
accurate in every particular but I am
sure it is sufficiently so for all the
uses I shall attempt to make of it and
in it we have before us the chief
material enabling us to correctly judge
whether the repeal of the Missouri
Compromise is right or wrong he pointed
to Douglases bold denial of the history
of the country as Lincoln also denounced
Tawny's opinion in dred scott as being
he said based on assumed historical
facts which are not really true we might
say that Lincoln was as much a historian
as he was a philosopher unfortunately
some professed admirers of Lincoln say
that he distorted or rewrote history in
order to give us a new and better
constitution and union as Garry wills
put it Lincoln engage in a giant if
benign swindle refounding America by
redefining the framers idea of equality
Lincoln's detractors on the other hand
say that he was forced into glory
originally defending a pro-slavery union
and constitution which was as the
radical abolitionist put it a covenant
with death and an agreement with hell
one that was only made worthy of the
saving after emancipation and
reconstruction
Justice Thurgood Marshall made this
argument in his 1987 comments on the
bicentennial of the Constitution what
these views share is the judgment that
Douglas and tawny were correct on the
historical point that Jefferson did not
have blacks in mind when he wrote that
all men are created equal and that the
founders were indifferent to or even
approving of slavery that azz tawny put
it in dred scott the founders are
guarded blacks as a subordinate and
inferior class of beings who had been
subjugated by the dominant race and
whether emancipated or not yet remains
subject to their authority and had no
rights or privileges but such as those
who held the power and the government
might choose to grant them it would take
too much time to retrace all the
historical evidence from the text of the
Constitution from other founding
documents from the founders other
writings and from the acts of the
National and the state governments that
established the anti-slavery character
of the original Constitution and the
historical argument is not one that is
beyond dispute Don fehrenbacher author
of the definitive history of the Dred
Scott case concluded that neither
Lincoln nor Tony could offer evidence to
cut to carry conviction that we
concluded the Lincoln was closer to the
truth than Tony but Lincoln's case for
the Union and to preserve Liberty based
on natural equality did not hinge in the
end on this historical argument as he
said at Peoria repeal them has already
compromised repeal all compromises
repeal the Declaration of Independence
repeal all past history you still cannot
repeal human nature and perhaps
Lincoln's greatest feat as a principled
statesman was his exposure of the
illogic of Steven Douglases territorial
sovereignty or pro-choice argument on
slavery all of their arguments instead
of Douglas and the Democrats will be
seen to exclude the thought that there
is anything whatever wrong and slavery
if you'll take the judges speeches and
select the short and pointed sentences
expressed by him as his declaration that
he don't care whether slavery is voted
up or voted down you will see it once
that this is perfectly logical if you do
not admit that slavery is wrong if you
do admit that it is wrong
Judge Douglas cannot logically say that
he don't care whether or wrong is voted
up or voted down Judge Douglas declares
that if any community wants slavery they
have a right to have it he can say that
logically if he says that there is no
wrong in slavery but if you admit that
there is a wrong in it he cannot
logically say that anybody has a right
to do wrong if our Constitution depends
is Hamilton put it in the first
Federalist on reflection and choice on
rational deliberation then certainly the
fundamental discipline of logic is
necessary to constitutional government
and Lincoln provided in an unparalleled
example of the use of logic in political
debate it is worth considering whether
Lincoln stated goal of making the Union
forever worthy of the saving implied
along the lines of the radical
abolitionists that the old Union as it
was before emancipation was not worthy
of the saving that is would the Civil
War or any war have been worth fighting
if it did not produce the end of slavery
Lincoln's answer was yes the original
Union and constitution were worth
fighting for he said at Peoria I to go
for saving the Union and much as I hate
slavery I would consent to the extension
of it rather than to see the Union
dissolve just as I would consent to any
great evil to avoid a greater one
Lincoln recognized and was willing to
abide by the compromises that the
Constitution made with slavery but this
willingness was conditioned on the
understanding that those compromises
were only such as were absolutely
necessary to preserve the Union in 1787
and that they were temporary again as
with the question of the founders
recognition of natural equality enslaves
there is room for argument as to how
much accommodation the constitution
provided perhaps too much perhaps more
than Lincoln admitted but this argument
was characteristic of Lincoln's
preeminent virtue of prudence prudence
or practical wisdom was the most
important requirement of the statesman
in contrast to the theoretical wisdom of
the philosopher or the mere political
agitator we must judge Lincoln according
to his exercise of prudence leading up
to and conducting the Civil War just as
we much
we must judge the founders according to
their Prudential judgment of compromise
involving slavery and the Constitution
but I think the evidence sustains
Lincoln's argument that the founders
were permitted that the founders
permitted slavery only insofar as they
had to and with the expectation that the
Union helped to put slavery in course of
ultimate extinction one might say that
here too the framers define the limits
of slavery with tolerable distinctness
in the Constitution but that subsequent
events interests and ideas when mike
allton heresies required further
definition Lincoln was a part of this
development of constitutional doctrine
this further definition or construction
of the Constitution was to be carried
out through the political institutions
established by the Constitution Lincoln
pointed out in his first inaugural that
there was no alternative to such
construction of the Constitution he
extended John Marshall's point that a
constitution to contain an accurate
detail of all the subdivisions of which
it's great powers will admit and of all
the means by which they may be carried
into execution would partake of the pro
lick city of a legal code and could
scarcely be embraced by the human mind
it would probably never be understood by
the public its nature therefore requires
that only its great outlines should be
marked it's important objects designated
and the minor ingredients which compose
those objects be deduced from the nature
of the objects themselves as Lincoln put
it no organic law can ever be framed
with a provision specifically applicable
to every question which may arise in
practical administration the
Constitution did not expressly say
whether Congress could permit or
prohibit slavery and the territories or
to enact a fugitive slave act the people
had to decide such questions through
elections and majority rule and Lincoln
gave what is to this day the best
statement that judicial interpretation
of the Constitution is not the complete
or final statement of the Constitution's
meaning he said again in response to the
Dred Scott decision I do not forget the
position assumed by some the
constitutional quest
are to be decided by the Supreme Court
nor do I deny that such decisions must
be binding in any case upon the parties
to a suit as to the object of that suit
while they are also entitled to very
high respect and consideration in all
parallel cases by other departments of
the government at the same time the
candid citizen must confess that if the
policy of the government upon vital
questions affecting the whole people is
to be irrevocably fixed by decisions of
the Supreme Court the instant they are
made in ordinary litigation between
parties and personal actions the people
will have ceased to be their own rulers
having to that extent practically resign
their government into the hands of that
eminent tribunal a lincoln did not deny
the legitimate place of the judiciary in
the constitutional system of checks and
balances nor did he deny the power of
judicial review or even of the courts
own power to go beyond the Constitution
and invoke natural law principles he
never disputed for example the authority
of the court in a particular case rather
he denied that the court could settle
important political questions through a
particular decision judicial decisions
he said are of greater or less authority
as precedence according to circumstances
if this important decision Dred Scott
had been made by the unanimous
concurrence of the judges and without
any apparent partisan bias and in
accordance with legal public expectation
and with the steady practice of the
departments throughout our history and
had been in no part based on assumed
historical facts which are not really
true or if wanting in some of these it
had been before the court more than once
and had been there affirmed and
reaffirmed through a course of years it
might be perhaps would be factious or
even revolutionary not to acquiesce in
it as a precedent but Dred Scott
certainly satisfied none of these
requirements that would make it a
binding precedent and Lincoln in the
Republicans explicitly challenged it and
took action to have it reversed this was
in keeping with his idea that the of the
people as the ultimate sovereign in our
constitutional system as he said in the
first inaugural a majority
eldon restrained by constitutional
checks and limitations and always
changing easily with deliberate changes
of popular opinions and sentiments is
the only true sovereign of a free people
Lincoln said at Peoria our Republican
robe is soiled and trailed in the dust
let us reap yura Phi it let us turn and
wash it white in the spirit if not the
blood of the revolution in the end
though it did require the blood of the
Civil War the conciliatory words of the
first inaugural failed to persuade
enough southerners to preserve the Union
the Lincoln claimed that no real
majority favored secession in any state
except South Carolina and so Lincoln had
to resort to force to save the Union in
his suppression of the rebellion
Lincoln's deeds showed how difficult it
is to maintain constitutional government
in wartime and here again we see
Lincoln's fidelity to the founders
Constitution in maintaining
constitutional government in wartime as
Herman belts puts it Lincoln repeatedly
turned to the text of the Constitution
as a guide to stay craft Lincoln
expressed what may be described as a
sense of constitutional fundamentalism
in his defense of the exercise of war
powers such as conscription and the
suspension of the writ of habeas corpus
the Constitution is quite explicit in
giving Congress the power to raise and
support armies and Lincoln regarding
conscription and it is worth noting the
very slight extent of conscription in
the Civil War as a reasonable means to
that end the Constitution also
explicitly provides for the suspension
of the writ of habeas corpus when in
cases of rebellion or invasion the
public safety may require however the
Constitution did not expressly say who
had the power to suspend the writ
Lincoln made the argument that it should
be primarily though perhaps not
exclusively the executive who had the
power and this construction of the
Constitution has prevailed again the
counter-argument is not without merit
and the question is to some degree still
being argued over today other actions
that Lincoln took particularly in the
early phase of the rebellion he told
Congress whether strictly legal or not
were ventured upon under what appeared
to be
a popular demand and a public necessity
trusting then is now that Congress would
readily ratify them it is believed that
nothing has been done beyond the
constitutional competency of Congress
Lincoln suggested that it might be
necessary to violate the law in order to
save the Union by general law he wrote
life and limb must be protected yet
often a limb must be amputated to save a
life but a life is never wisely given to
save a limb or as he put it to Congress
are all the laws but one to go on
executed and the government itself go to
pieces lest that one be violated but
this was largely hypothetical Lincoln
never admitted that he had violated the
law the most that he can be said to have
admitted is that it he might have done
so had circumstances required it and
again this would be a question of
prudence indeed Lincoln is usually
criticized for not taking bolder action
with regard to emancipation for allowing
his constitutional scruples to delay
justice this comes from critics on the
Left who regard Lincoln is being
insufficiently committed to racial
equality thus the historian Richard
Hofstadter noted that the Emancipation
Proclamation had none of the soaring
rhetoric of the Gettysburg Address or
the second inaugural it had he said all
the moral grandeur of a bill of leading
of course there are good constitutional
reasons for this Lincoln would go no
further than the Constitution permitted
in the exercise of executive power and
wanted to make sure that such action as
he took would be sustained after the war
moreover although Hofstadter meant to be
snide about it a bill of lading was
exactly what was called for it enabled
his Martin Luther King jr. would put it
in the 20th century african-americans to
redeem the promissory note of racial
equality perhaps the most important
thing that Lincoln did in exercising
presidential power during the Civil War
was to keep that power tethered to the
parts of the Constitution that conferred
executive power his power is
commander-in-chief of the Armed Forces
the presidential oath to preserve
protect and defend the Constitution and
the provision that he see that the laws
be faithfully executed
and the Republican Party did not use the
war as a pretext to extend the power of
the government in peacetime while
Lincoln did appropriately preserve
executive power against legislative
encroachment particularly toward the end
of the war with regard to reconstruction
he has rightly been called a wig in the
White House deferential to Congress
worth regard to matters not directly
connected to the war Lincoln and the
Republicans have been accused by
libertarians especially of using the war
to establish a Leviathan state a
precursor to 20th century big government
and it is true that Lincoln signed all
of the bills that expanded federal power
during the wore the protective tariffs
the national Banking Act the Pacific
Railroad act and the first-ever income
tax among others I would argue that
these were all de sensible on
constitutional grounds although there
are strong arguments against some of
them and some of these acts were liable
to abuse nevertheless they were not
beyond the limits of most Antebellum
constitutional arguments made by the
Federalists and the Whigs many of them
were legitimately related to the war
power or other legitimate federal powers
and many of them most notably the income
tax were temporary in short Lincoln's
wartime statesmanship showed that the
Constitution was adequate to meet the
conditions of war and emergency now what
does Lincoln's example mean for us today
certainly with regard to unborn children
and the terminally ill we need to face
the question of humanity and the equal
right to life more broadly we face the
question of whether the federal
government is doing those things that
the Constitution permits it to do and
whether it is fulfilling the purposes
for which governments are instituted
among men the protection of our natural
rights we are among the succeeding
millions of happy people the world over
who Lincoln said would rise up and call
those who save the Union in the 19th
century blessed to the latest
generations we need someone with
Lincoln's understanding of the
Constitution of morals of logic and of
history to teach and shape public
opinion so that we can pass on
constitutional government to our own
future generations thank you
I'll invite members of the studio
audience to an address questions such a
professor moreno we're going to start
off with a question from our online
participant pool Peter from Michigan
asks the following question how could
Lincoln acknowledge the right of
secession to the States against England
but not against the federal government
well I think the crucial distinction
there is between secession and with
Lincoln and it's what everybody
recognizes legitimate right to
revolution late Lincoln never denied
that again in circumstances in which
fundamental natural rights were being
violated when the government had become
destructive of the ends for which
governments were instituted that people
had a natural right to revolution to
alter and abolish their forms of
government and that's what the American
colonists did in 1776 successfully
exercise their right of revolution
against the British secession though is
something fundamentally different it was
a a doctrine invented between the
American Revolution in the civil war
that tried to say that there was a
lawful and constitutional way of
breaking up the government without
exactly calling it revolution right and
that's what Lincoln denied basically
Lincoln denied that the American
colonists did not secede from the
British Empire they exercise their
legitimate right to revolution and
Lincoln in the first inaugural told the
seceding states there is a right
revolution and you can exercise it if
it's justified right and then Lincoln
went on to establish that you know there
is there any clearly written
constitutional right that has been
violated up until this one is there are
there any legitimate grounds by which
you can justify the right for revolution
that Lincoln said there had been not
this is again where he said that all the
questions that are in dispute in 1860
about the return of fugitive slaves
about slavery in the territories Lincoln
said the Constitution does not
presley provide an answer for those
questions therefore we must vote upon we
must have majority rule there's no
there's no alternative to that so
Lincoln said if a clearly stated
constitutional right we're being
violated it might justify the right to
revolution but that is not the case in
1860 and so you have a situation that is
not not analogous between 1776 and in
1860 essentially there was no such thing
as a session there is the right to
revolution but the right to revolution
in order to be exercised has to be based
upon a serious violations of natural
rights this is the way the Jefferson put
it in the Declaration of Independence
recess that people are more inclined to
suffer violations of their natural
rights while those evils are tolerable
than they are to exercise their right
and their duty to overthrow government
and to exercise the the right to
revolution but even Jefferson says it's
not for every light and transient cause
that you can exercise the right to
revolution there has to be a long train
of abuses and usurpations which has the
end of tyranny and view in slavery in
view to justify their yah the right to
revolution and that was the case in 1776
it was not the case in in 1860 in 1776
you could say if you read all the
grievances in the Declaration of
Independence you can say they all boil
down to the statement that parliament
made in the declaratory act that
Parliament has the power to legislate
for the American colonies in all cases
whatsoever write a statement of absolute
sovereignty right has potentially no no
limitation to tyranny there was no such
power that was being claimed by other
Republican Party or the people are going
to take over the government in 1861 the
circumstances of or the conditions
necessary to exercise the right to
revolution did not obtain
we have another online question this one
comes from chip in Clearwater Florida
what of Lincoln's infamous statements
such as the following if I could save
the Union without freeing slaves I would
do it and also quote I have never been
in favor of bringing about the Equality
of the white and black races how do you
square these statements with the notion
that he was somehow higher minded in
what he attempted to accomplish now the
first one is a statement from the letter
that he wrote to Horace Greeley at a
point of which abolitionists were urging
Lincoln to make emancipation and
abolition more explicitly the goal of
the of the government's policy in the
Civil War and Lincoln insisted that his
principal goal was to save the Union and
that everything that he did in order to
with regard to slavery in order to save
the Union but depended upon that
question of whether it advanced or
undermined that effort and he said if I
could save the Union by freeing all the
slaves I would do that if I could save
the Union by keeping them all slaves I
would do that and if I could save the
Union by freeing some and leaving others
alone I would do that it's worth noting
that at the time that Lincoln wrote that
letter to hardest Greeley he had already
prepared the draft of the Emancipation
Proclamation so he had already moved
from the point of leaving slavery alone
where it existed right which was the
professed policy of the Republican Party
in 1860 and one that Lincoln stood by to
the next step of freeing some and
leaving others alone the Emancipation
Proclamation didn't apply to all states
only those behind rebel lines and then
ultimately the end of the war Lincoln
goes to the point of endorsing and
taking quite a bit of effort to get
Congress to introduce the 13th amendment
to the states to abolish slavery
everywhere and I think it goes back to
the quote that I read from Lincoln where
he said yes he would even accept the
expansion of slavery rather than destroy
the Union just as I would accept a bad
thing to avoid a worse than so again
this is the question of prudence and it
goes back also the question of the
compromises that the founders made with
slavery in the original Constitution
what would have been the alternative
right if you hadn't had a union in 17
87 1789 if people's principles about no
Union with slaveholders was so great as
to break up the union would that have
been better for human Liberty for blacks
and for lights or worse again arguably
and this is a Prudential a question the
founders were correct in thinking that
by keeping the Union together by
compromising with slavery at least in
the short run we actually make it more
likely to bring about the ultimate
extinction of slavery and again people
can argue about whether the founders
were correct in this Lincoln was very
much aware that circumstances had had
changed because of the invention of the
cotton gin especially the reasonable
expectation that the founders had that
within two or three generations slavery
would be gone things had changed we
can't compromise so much anymore in the
1860s Lincoln was not forced to take
this position but if he had consented to
maintaining the union with slavery how
long would it have taken for slavery to
have been abolished and was that a
better thing than the the Civil War and
the way that it brought about the end of
slavery and that's say that's a
debatable point but the idea that
Lincoln and the founders had that what
they were doing by keeping the Union
together was ultimately in the end the
best thing to promote what they would
Lincoln referred to as liberty to all i
think is defensible on on Prudential
grounds the second question is that the
political and social equality of blacks
and it is true the Lincoln did say in
the lincoln-douglas debates that he was
not in favor of bringing about the
social and political equality of blacks
and whites blacks couldn't vote for
instance in a new annoyed in most states
and Lincoln said that that was not part
of his part of his agenda on the other
hand lincoln did certainly develop
towards the idea of greater civil and
political rights for blacks by the end
of the Civil War especially once blacks
participated after the Emancipation
Proclamation in the Union Army and it
began to have a great impact on northern
public opinion generally the idea that
if blacks showed that they were capable
of fighting to save the Union that the
extension of civil
political rights I should follow
Lincoln's last speech indeed the one
that could well say cause his
assassination was an appeal to the
reconstruction government of Louisiana
to extend the right to vote to at least
some some blacks so link was certainly
moving in the direction towards greater
civil and politically equality and we
have the quotation from Stephen Douglas
in the the reader about saying that
Lincoln Douglas is impression was a
Lincoln shared the prejudices of most
white people of his time but that he you
know had come to the patis a very loud
and passionate voice in favor of
equality and Lincoln certainly was
moving in the direction of greater civil
and political equality as a historian
although you don't want to force the
issue there were certainly I think you
could say limitations to Lincoln's view
of racial equality by 20th century
standards that's true but compared to
the Americans of his generation link was
certainly leading in the way towards
greater civil and political equality
this is a great deal of online interest
will stick with online questions this
comes from Scott in Bakersfield
California the Fourteenth Amendment has
been the subject of much debate what is
its meaning properly understood all
right so we have two or three weeks to
talk about this one to take on the the
Fourteenth Amendment it's an amazing
thing when you consider that the
constitution of 1787 doesn't contain the
sort of sort of very much sort of
substantive rights language you get in
the Fourteenth Amendment due process of
law privileges and immunities equal
protection of the law right most of the
Constitution is about very specific
things the structure of the government
the terms of office and things like that
yet there was an incredible detailed
elaborate debate about the meaning of
the Constitution you know that fills
volumes right on the other hand the
Fourteenth Amendment uses this language
that is in many ways open-ended to to
sort of substantive interpretations
especially about the the meaning of
rights yet there was very little debate
within Congress and in the state
the states that ratified it as to what
the language of the Fourteenth Amendment
means and that's why it is so prone and
has gone through so many different and
very varied modes of interpretation in
many ways the the analogous case to the
to the Fourteenth Amendment was the
Fifth Amendment in the original
Constitution in the in the Bill of
Rights and thus you had both the
pro-slavery people and the anti-slavery
people it's making fifth amendment what
we come to be called substantive due
process arguments about slavery in the
territories in short jhansi Calhoun and
Justice tani in dred scott say look the
Fifth Amendment says you can't be
deprived of property without due process
of law so Congress can enact a law that
prohibits people from taking their slave
property into the territories right
abolitionists on the other hand say the
Fourteenth Amendment prohibits the
taking of Liberty without due process of
law therefore Congress must prohibit
slavery in the territories I likewise
the Fourteenth Amendment has been used
for a number of different purposes its
language about a due process especially
although in many ways all the provisions
of the Fourteenth Amendment privileges
and immunities due process and equal
protection will do the same work if you
have a guarantee of fundamental rights
claims now I think the big problem with
the Fourteenth Amendment and dr.
Spalding mentioned this in the last talk
was the sort of way in which the
judiciary has established a monopoly in
interpreting the Constitution right and
this is where Lincoln's argument against
Dred Scott in the first inaugural that
we are we're all part the people through
their institutions not the people you
know all mass not via a sort of
referendum process ought to be the ones
can screw construing and defining what
those phrases mean in the Fourteenth
Amendment because I have to mean
something I mean they're not just a sort
of boilerplate there are questions of
fundamental rights that are at issue
that are being protected by the
Fourteenth Amendment but it ought not to
be the exclusive province of judges to
determine what those rights are that the
people their elected officials various
devices by which we can do what Lincoln
said in the first inaugural to make sure
that the people are their own rulers at
the
people are the ones interpreting what
the 14th amendment means not just not
just the judges this question comes from
Jessica from Eden Prairie Minnesota
Abraham Lincoln admired Henry Clay but
Lincoln himself was a Republican what
might Lincoln think of the GOP today
well the first part of that is I think
easier to uh to answer yes he did he
admired Henry Clay Henry Clay was his as
Lincoln putted his beau ideal of a
statesman and Lincoln was very reluctant
to leave the Whig party as it was
dissolving into to become a Republican
who's very very cautious about that so I
would say that well if Henry Clay had
lived as many wigs I did in most ways
especially the northern wigs the
Republican Party was the successor of
the of the week party well with Lincoln
think of the Republican party today
again that's I don't want to be
excessively partisan about this but I
would say yeah he would still be a
Republican because the Republican Party
is closer to the principles of the of
the Constitution than the than the
alternative it's so I do think that
Lincoln would certainly be in
interpreting the Constitution the
founding principles the way that that
Lincoln did is exactly what the
Republican party needs today there are
some people in the GOP that are still
able to go back to the founding
documents and make the connection
between what government does in the
Constitution and especially the
principles behind the Constitution but
there aren't enough of them
mike from washington state asks
federalism is a concept that you alluded
to and talked about how does it differ
from the understanding of states rights
and do states have rights so that's a
good question and you could say that
Lincoln was indeed a federalist or an
advocate of the again constitutionally
reserved powers of the states in the
first inaugural Lincoln repeated that
part of the 1860 Republican platform in
which it said the preservation in violet
of the rights of the states is the basis
on which our constitutional system
depends basically this this principle of
the division of power between the
federal government's federal government
in the States and the idea especially
that the assumption under the
Constitution is the powers of the
national government are delegated right
there enumerated and we assume that if
the Constitution doesn't express Presley
give the grant power it's not there
right we assume on the other hand that
states have the general depository of
general governmental powers sometimes
referred to as the police power and
unless the Constitution withholds power
from the state it belongs to the state
so the Republican Party of eighteen
sixty was still committed to that basic
founding Madisonian idea of the compound
republic the term of states rights
though on the other hand I would say
that's not quite right and it's one that
I try to avoid using and people
individuals have rights the whole point
of government is to protect our rights
we ought not to talk about government as
having rights government has powers
right unfortunately in the 20th century
and dr. Freda we'll talk about this more
this afternoon but that's the whole
problem that we have in this twentieth
century transformation of this idea of
Rights that what we people tend to call
today writes things like housing and
health care and all that you know those
are not rights right those are those are
entitlements things that government
power is required to provide
people with so I'm one of the great
feats of twentieth-century progressives
and liberals was to transform the
meaning of this term rights and of
liberalism so that today if you're
somebody particularly be called a
conservative today you sound for the
most part like a 19th century liberal
they've hijacked the terms rights and i
think this this discussion of states
rights would be another example of words
that are not properly being used now you
go back to the declaration of dependence
and the natural rights philosophy of
John Locke and a lot of other 18th
century thinkers right it is precisely
the protection of the rights that
individuals have by nature in the state
of nature that we form governments to
protect those rights and we give
government's power in order to do so
right government needs to make sure that
we you know we don't steal from one
another we don't prey upon one another
it's a proper power of government to
make sure that we abide by the promises
that we make in contracts those are the
things that we give government's power
to do but improperly speaking
governments do not have rights only
individuals have rights Karen from
Charlottesville Virginia to the 14th
amendment or does the 14th amendment or
any other often misinterpreted part of
the Constitution necessitate today a
constitutional convention to clarify
those provisions I don't know if I would
say that it necessitated one I think
there are there are ways in which the
Constitution could be properly construed
to sort of rain in some of the problems
that it's been that it has has brought
up I think what the Supreme Court did
recently with regard to mccain-feingold
was a good example of the court
returning to a really fundamentally
proper understanding of freedom of
speech under the First Amendment I tend
to think that amending the Constitution
too much let alone I mean a
constitutional convention there many got
pretty close to this in the 1980s about
the balance
I issue how would that actually work you
know what would be the ground rules by
which a constitutional convention
operated the Constitution really doesn't
say much explicitly about this at all so
I'd want some pretty clear guarantees
that it wouldn't you know sort of go off
the rails before resorting to that
expedient but again the way the people
do have through the constitutional
institutions that are still there and
it's still operating we still have
elections we still have different
branches of government there are still
ways in which the courts can be brought
under control I still think we have the
mechanisms in place they need to be
exercised more perhaps but I think are
the constitutional structure is still in
place in such a way that we can begin
the process of restoring proper limited
constitutional government again as dr.
Spalding pointed out very able toward
the end of his talk am this requires
brunch you can't just go in and talk the
number of things that Congress has done
that are beyond the Constitution's grant
of power are legion right there you
wouldn't know where to start and you
can't sweep them away all at once but
the process of restoration needs to be
one that is done and tactically
strategically with due attention to a
popular opinion and that's exactly I
think what Lincoln was doing right
lincoln did I think ultimately and in
some sense Lincoln was an abolitionist
his view was that ultimately we are
going to do away with slavery but his
process before the war especially his
his approach was you contain it you keep
it out of the territories then you
convinced the southern states especially
that they need to begin to take up a
policy of gradual and compensated
emancipation and Lincoln propose to do
that through existing political
institutions especially through the the
state legislatures and indeed Lincoln
was trying to get Congress to promote
this among the states well into the
Civil War so I think again a Lincoln's
policy of prudence would be the one to
want to follow
from Jon & Hermitage Tennessee Lincoln's
second inaugural and many other of his
speeches are full of references to the
divine what was Lincoln's understanding
of the public role of religion um again
I think Lakeland although the American
founders established through Z a regime
in which we had a civil and political
and religious liberty and they do have
toleration and pluralism was certainly
the the predominant one at the time of
the American Founding nevertheless this
certainly did not exclude the the place
or presence of religion in public life
right the separation of church and state
and the idea of no established churches
is one thing but the idea that people
are not able to bring their religious
views into public life and to the
formation of public policy was far from
what the founders had in view and from
what what what Lincoln had into you the
question of Lincoln's own religious
commitments just sort of putting that to
the side Lincoln was aware that the
United States was a profoundly Christian
country Lincoln for example said that he
supported an effort to amend the
Constitution to explicitly state that
the United States was a Christian
country so Lincoln was perfectly aware
of the the good that religion could play
in public life and the second inaugural
of course is the the classic example of
that most concise explanation to this
day of what the Civil War was was
ultimately about and Lincoln seeing it
as God's judgment on the country for the
the sin of slavery again toward the end
of his life Lincoln had been moved I
think to see more more profoundly the
ultimately religious dimension of what
was going on in America
Phil from Scottsdale rights you talked a
lot about Lincoln's ideas what was
Lincoln like as an as a man as an
individual what made him great well it's
like I think like most great men Lincoln
was very hard to actually get to know
and he had few intimate friends although
he was again a very gregarious and very
public person a great storyteller a
great serac on tour Stephen Douglas was
you know sort of afraid of being you
need to debate with Lincoln because of
his just a wonderful effect upon people
yet he remains something of an enigmatic
figure as a man to this day as perhaps
all all great men are um what made him
great from again did the perspective of
the American political and
constitutional experience was his again
it's I think his willingness to resist
the temptation of power and to remain
committed to what he put it in one of
his early speeches as the preservation
of our political institutions Lincoln
himself was aware of the great danger
throughout human history of people who
desired greatness and Lincoln was
certainly a man who desired greatness
and ambition his law partner William
Herndon said that his ambition was a
little engine that knew no rest but the
Lincoln was not going to destroy the
Republic for the sake of establishing
his own greatness that that the problem
that Republican governments have
especially the American regime is that
the founders established something that
was you know was good and what we needed
to do was to preserve it and perpetuate
it Lincoln said but there are some
people those of the race of the lion and
the tribe of the eagle or something like
that wouldn't be enough for them to do
that just to pass on the blessings of
liberty from your ancestors to your
descendants is not going to be enough to
satisfy the desire of really ambitious
men people like like Napoleon some
people Lincoln said in order to
establish their own greatness would
would flinch it nothing even if it meant
the emancipation of slaves or the
enslavement of
reman Eddie and Lincoln's detractors
have said that in the speech he was sort
of prophesying his own destruction of
the of the traditional constitutional
system and the establishment of a new
one but I think Lincoln's greatness lies
in the fact that he did not do that and
that despite the again cataclysmic Civil
War the United States came through that
with a returned a clearer statement of
what the founding principles were and
that Lincoln was able to again pass on a
constitutional republic to the next
generation of Americans I think if you
look at the Civil War the effect that it
had upon american society in the
american economy and all that work we're
pretty great but nevertheless after the
Civil War what's remarkable is how
quickly politics and constitutional
government returned to its antebellum a
way of way of doing things that you
didn't establish as state of them that
Bismarck was doing in Russia or Cavour
and Italy the United States had a
million-man army at the end of the Civil
War but we didn't keep it after the war
was over everyone went home the great
expansion of executive power during the
Civil War and Lincoln as I made the
argument was properly vigorously
exercising his powers as commander in
chief but nevertheless you return to the
sort of normal condition of legislative
predominance and executive sort of
deference in the years after the Civil
War so Lincoln did not think in the
Republicans generally did not take the
Civil War as an opportunity to
fundamentally transform the American
Republic and to again in peacetime
continue not the extraordinary powers of
wartime 20th century liberalism is just
the opposite you hear the progressives
and liberals in the 20th century
constantly trying to talk about domestic
social policy in Marshall terms right
Theodore Roosevelt does this all the
time franklin delano roosevelt and his
first inaugural talking about the
depression uses explicitly military
analogy and you hear this all the time
today people talking about the war on
drugs or the war on poverty of the war
on on whatever the grade one of the
great virtues of Lincoln of the
Republicans was they resisted the
opportunities for sort of unlimited
government
that the Civil War presented thank you
very much